hey everybody welcome to Fantasy Valley
part 6 this video is going to be a
little bit more slow-paced than the rest
of this series because I'm trying to do
something new at least I haven't done it
before at least not on this sense and
this skill and I haven't seen anybody
else do it either and if the reason that
I'm doing it is also more or less out of
necessity
basically you might know that I'm trying
to go for an Asian theme with this part
of the park here and there isn't any
kind of Asian theme in the game and
there aren't too many Asian pieces in
the game either so that's a bit of a
problem and the only way that I figured
I could really get over that and save
myself quite a bit of time and troubles
at some point later in the future is to
try and make a custom set of Asian roofs
to you since roofs are really the most
dominant and like visible and
recognizable parts of Asian buildings or
at least we're talking about East Asian
so this area is mostly inspired by China
and Japan and it's that kind of
architecture which I want to get into
this specific part so the way that I
wanted to make that set is start off
with a very basic piece which all of the
other pieces will be based on which
existed which is just very simple a full
tile roof that's slightly gentle goes
down a bit and has barely any
decorations on it and from there kind of
used that as a template to make all of
the other pieces that hopefully together
and I didn't test that at this point so
I am really happy that it at least
worked out somewhat in the end together
all of those pieces should be able to be
combined to make all sorts of different
shapes and sizes and kinds of roofs that
you would want to make for this style so
the second groove type that I wanted to
get into is the corner roof which is the
tricky bit since the Asian buildings are
definitely most famous for their like
curved points of the roofs so I had to
get that in here and the trouble with
this is not just that the roof itself
curves a bit it goes from very steep on
the top to very gentle on the bottom but
the curves are like the corners of the
roofs also curve upwards a bit so
there's like two different curves in
here which makes it all a bit awkward to
place all of the different pieces and
make sure that they're all in the right
position and don't overlap in strange
ways because I wanted to get this
looking as clean as I could you might
know that these types of roofs are
actually supposed to be tiled roofs
which is not really the case in here
since there aren't just any tiled roof
pieces which I could use to make this
kind of groove for it exactly in the
shape and style that I wanted to so
instead I'm using some wooden planks and
wooden pillars to try and get the
general look of what the tiled roofs
would look like especially with those
big cubular roof tiles that go down and
the horizontal smaller roof tiles that
were laid in between those sort of make
the same pattern with the wood but in
the end it's not exactly the same look
and you can't exactly get that same
texture so in the end it is kind of
echoing for an asian-looking roof
without it actually being all that
correct so if you would zoom on a zoom
in on this quite a bit you definitely
notice that it's made out of wood and a
proper textured but the goal of this was
to basically make some roofs that would
work to make a general Asian looking
maybe slightly fantasy like theme about
which I also kind of have to say I
didn't get too many comments about this
but I did set out to make this a fantasy
Park with real-life counterparts which
all of the different sections of the
park are based on but so far I haven't
really gone into the fantasy realm that
much and
that's something which I do want to do a
bit more in the future and I won't do
extremely weird things and we're not
going to go into the fantasy realm of
floating islands and things like that
but at least mix different styles just
the very fact that I'm trying to put
together Japanese and Chinese
architecture and sort of make it one
theme in this case is already a bit
strange but we'll get into like some
bigger and more impressive buildings
hopefully at some point in the future
but first I really needed to get these
routes in and make sure that that's
alright so the next roof that I needed
to make was the roof on the side because
I also need quite a few Gables for these
kinds of roofs so the way that I've
wanted to try that is quickly make that
thing on the side here and connect those
beams that I just made on the side to a
regular roof and get some extra
decorations on top of that which are
like the big ridges that you see on top
of many of these kinds of roofs so I'll
get in a few of these ridges as well and
the idea is that in the end we'll have
all sorts of different pieces we have
the corner piece we have the straight
piece and we have Ridge pieces gable
pieces and steep pieces and more gentle
pieces so that you can combine them all
and basically make any kind of roof
shape out of it and the final piece I
think no this is almost the final piece
but it is a very important piece is the
top of the roof which is used for some
larger roofs and to get a bit more of a
steep angle in there so this one is just
straight and supposed to be used with
the already curved roofs to make them a
bit higher and this one also has that
big bridge on top of that as the
decoration now these roofs I think are
actually the very last roofs and the
biggest ones that I needed for any kind
of large gable and one little annoying
thing about this is that I had to make
two different roofs for each side for
this kind of thing since they have the
decorations on top of it and I wanted to
keep it quite modular but this actually
caused some issues later on because why
didn't talk about yet but what I did
off-screen and you won't see me doing
that much is recolor all of these roofs
so that we have different colors of
roofs as well to work with the only
problem with that was that all this time
I figured I could just select everything
and give that one call at once but turns
out I actually have to select every kind
of object at a time so that took a lot
of time to do so skipping forward a
little bit to the actual building
process at this point
I finished the sets and I've got a
couple of different colors we've got the
green roof that I'm starting out with
here we've got the golden roof which
supposedly is only used for castles or
palaces and like prestigious buildings
in China but we're just gonna well use
it for pretty much anything here I've
got some black roofs that could fit in
with the roofs of the pagoda which by
the way I didn't want to go with the
roofs the pagoda here since they are
smaller and not supposed to be used on
full tiles but anyway yeah I've also got
some red roofs I believe and that should
be it for all of the different colors
that I have and that should be just fine
enough to get a good variety of colors
in all of these buildings now what I
wanted to do first with these roofs is
make some buildings on the side of the
Rocky Mountain here the plan was always
to kind of have a bunch of facades here
at the back of the coaster to not just
mask the mountain and not so great fake
rock work behind it but also just make
this a bit more of a town like scene and
help the pagoda look a little bit larger
than it is because all of these
buildings are gonna stay quite low and
just kind of be a bit of an addition to
make the rest of this area look a bit
better instead of drawing too much
attention to themselves but still this
was a lot of fun to mess around with and
see what you can actually do with the
theme so the first building is just
super simple or at least the way that
it's set up basically just the gable on
the front of it
three floors with the roof on the bottom
floor and the balcony on the second
floor or the first floor I should know
that's the second floor yep
and that is really the basic shape and I
will touch a few other smaller facades
on the right of this one but this is
more or less going to be the biggest
building of this view here and it's also
the first to be adding a bit more of a
Chinese touch to this area obviously the
green roofs I wanted to get in here just
to get some different colors almost
everything up to this point has been red
or orange so there's a lot of those same
colors around here but in general this
really feels like a more Chinese
building I'm not that much into Chinese
buildings but there is not a very large
build our difference between Japanese
and Chinese but some of the big
differences is that Chinese buildings
rarely paints the outsides
so Chinese buildings often have a lot of
painted woodwork and a lot of very
different lush colors
whereas Japanese buildings usually just
keep the same old boring gray brownish
color of the woodwork and don't paint
their stuff as much so Chinese buildings
are usually much more colorful and with
that hopefully we should be able to get
some more color into this area and the
most while the only probably in the end
really Japanese building in this area is
going to stay the pagoda which should
hopefully still blend in quite a bit
with the more Chinese building since it
is quite a colorful pagoda but I
probably shouldn't think about that
stuff so much and I'm trying to do it
less since really the fantasy idea
behind this Park is to stop worrying so
much about making things look entirely
realistic and just go off the plan for a
bit here and there and just do some more
fun playful things also it's just kind
of like a theme park and architecture
architecture in a theme park isn't
always exactly realistic or conform to
the standards of whatever they're trying
to go for but just whatever looks good
is gonna work and I guess that's what
I'm hopefully gonna go for with this
fantasy theme as well just go beyond
what the theme should be and do some fun
stuff every now and then
now another thing that I had to do is
actually gap some path work in which I
struggled with for quite a bit but in
the end I'm quite happy with it the path
work isn't going to be strictly the path
work that is actually functional and
ingame because it's really hard to get
that type of path to lead everywhere in
a sense that theme-park paths go I think
the path system in the game is good the
only problem with it is still and I know
I've complained about this for quite a
bit but it the problem with it still is
that it's not very theme-park
ish at least it isn't easy to get that
in theme parks are often very large
stretches of concrete very wide and
winding paths and this kind of path
system is much better for narrow paths
such as kind of snake through an area
which is not what I'm trying to do here
so most of these paths something to keep
in mind are made to have different
sidewalks that are just made out of
scenery and not actual paths beside them
and this entire area down here at the
base of these buildings is gonna be
almost entirely part with just a few
planters and open spaces for some trees
in between but there's gonna be quite
some large stretches of concrete in here
so that's the idea to keep in mind for
this whole area the windows actually are
one of the easier things of making Asian
buildings in this case since many either
just have these very large open when
those kind of panels or just paper
panels which is quite easy to get in but
I do want to experiment a bit more in
the future with different pieces to make
them since it might start looking very
boring if I keep using the same windows
everywhere but for now these ones won't
just work for pretty much all of the
buildings that we have in here
just connecting this way to the pagoda
very quickly this is also not gonna be
functional
since the host is no way that I could
actually get a path in game to go
precisely where I want that staircase to
go but I guess in a fantasy way if this
would be a real park it would be amazing
to well at least walk over to the pagoda
and be able to take that small path over
the bridge and check that out there
which would be the idea here it's just
not gonna be able to happen in a game
functional way now with this fence I'm
just closing off the river for a bit
I got a few comments actually about this
asking if I would actually add water to
the lower part of the river at the other
side of the bridge here which doesn't
have any water yet I'll certainly do so
at some point in the future but not
quite yet it's is that to get those
waterfalls in there especially since
it's a very gentle slope I would have to
well have a lot of trial and error with
the precise placement of the water VFX
which takes a lot of time and a lot of
pausing and unpausing the game and I
actually love being on just about well
10 a.m. on this part of the park since
that would mean that the Sun is coming
on
well almost directly onto the Rocky
Mountain here which is just about the
best angle of light to work on maybe I
care about that a little bit too much
but bottom line is we'll get in a
waterfall at some point in the future
over there
it's just not happening quite yet it
might actually happen in the next
episode in which I'll do a lot of
gardening around this area but I'm not
entirely supposed to spoil the next
episode already see our last building of
this very small part of the facade here
which I'll be working on in this video
is just a quick building which I had a
bit of trouble with figuring out what I
wanted to do for a bit this was pretty
much just improvised and kind of hoping
that I would figure out stuff along the
way and in the end I decided to leave
out that top part since this is a very
narrow stretch of land and it would
either clash with the little or with the
with the flying coaster on the other
side so in the end it's just a very
narrow and not even that tall part of
the facade here just to make sure that I
at least have the mountain covered up
but have a building that just fits into
the space and that is quite simple as
well they're actually a couple of other
things that I want to talk about just
because I had a few comments about them
and I at least want to get that out
there and talk about all of the feedback
that I got and then actually put into
the park as well the layouts of the
coaster especially around this turn in
here isn't really that good and I have
to say flying coasters aren't really one
of my strong points and in hindsight
there are just some things about this
layout that are not really up to
standards for a flying coaster or just
outright bad and one of those points is
actually the curve right here which
would be pretty forceful when you're
lying on your back right here and I'm
not too sure if I'm gonna keep it in
it's not too bad though the only thing
is that it's gonna have to be stretched
out a bit more so this will be lowered a
bit right now the track is very close to
the buildings here but it will be
lowered and that curve will be sort of
stretched out to have the track go a
little bit further away from the
buildings but also have that curve be a
bit larger so it's less forceful and
another point which I will change in the
next episode at the end of it is going
to be the Immelman at the beginning of
the coaster we have that half loop and a
twist after that to go back to a flying
position that's gonna be removed and
instead we're gonna have a twist right
at the drop and have the half loop after
that as a sort of half pretzel loop
basically what's gonna happen is that
the loop is gonna be reversed right now
it's kind of like an inverted loop and
it's gonna be a regular one almost
because at the moment it would launch
you into the harness of the coaster
really forcefully
reversing that's to kind of make it a
half pretzel like many flying coasters
would have seems like a bit of a better
option layout wise and another point is
the rockwork behind these buildings and
I am well pretty well aware that it's
not the best idea to be making that book
work out of literal rock work as a
scenery object from the game instead of
just terraforming which would save lots
of time or at the very least it will
save a lot of Polly's in the game and
maybe make it look a bit better the
thing is just I've tried to get some
sedimentary rock layers and realistic
Rock results out of the in-game
terraforming tool but I just failed and
whether that's just me I'm not that good
with a terraforming tool pretty bad
actually really bad or whether that's
just the fact that it's not possible
because I haven't really figured out any
texture that you could really make to
get some sedimentary rock layers or Rock
shapes in the Rock work basically it
doesn't work out so I've chosen to go
with regular rocks which was it kind of
helps to make it look a bit more theme
park ish because the idea with the rocks
is definitely not to make a realistic
mountain or make a realistic cliffside
but just make one that looks like it's a
theme park and like it's actually out of
poured concrete or whatever in the theme
park chose to make it out of so it's in
a way supposed to look like a fake
mountain that's the idea at least but I
will work on the rock work and the
coastal a how it a bit more in the
future and refine them pretty much
whatever comes up and if there are ways
to make things better I'm always happy
to get some comments about it because I
definitely can't do everything right on
my own but yeah that is just about
everything I wanted to say about that
back to the time-lapse I just finished
the building of pretty quickly there I
wanted to change a couple of things in
last minute just because the windows are
looking super similar at this point and
I will want to at least have some bigger
differences and variety in wall textures
in the future but the last part that I
want to do still in this video is the
beginnings of the plaza in front of it
most of this will be made in the next
episode
I wanted to get us all starts get an
idea of what it's going to look like
still in this video basically what we're
gonna have is a two heights of the plaza
so in the middle of it we'll have a bit
of planter action with some trees and
bushes and both sides are gonna have
pretty wide paths with sidewalks and
right in the middle of that we're gonna
have this staircase which leads up or
leads down basically connects them and
pretty much cuts straight through what
is going to be the planter area at some
point in the future and it's also a good
way to get in some different fences
which I want to try and get as much
variety in as I can as well last but not
least we have some finishing touches a
couple of extra paths on the side of the
real paths a bit of rock work to kind of
blend everything together and a tiny bit
of foliage as well and that's it for
this episode's time-lapse
so thank you guys for watching and I
hope to see you guys next time
[Music]
you
[Music]